the award for Niko the all good in the
hood award says he's still good at
archery I made him a little bust of a
funny-looking a little boy with a Robin
Hood hat did it do it's such a bad print
though no jakey as before it's pretty
he's great
it's not like I'm s model for printing
touched it's not just model I just took
the head off of turbosquid and then I
modeled everything else see a mustache
or is that just enough no I I tried to
make the lips like in a smiling position
but then it kind of just made this like
weird like if you are going to VidCon
this year we will be there like we are
every year you guys are going to be
there look for us I'd love to say hi
love to meet you guys big great time on
my facebook I'm watching people play
things maybe they like we written right
there in that bag like them I do like
the vlogs where people sit there and
they go okay so I think I've worked yet
same as responsibility is this Niko's
death what does he do okay I'll sit the
guy they all kind of do the same thing
yes a wild clip women in the group of
people versus and then like baby you
have to watch them walk the entire time
so you're missing your Marine training
today yeah I'm supposed to swim 600
meters today Marine training every
morning yeah dude great yeah clock yeah
doing doing that again eh
would you leave that with really what
yeah so yeah yeah that's intense like
it's like five and one you're like oh
yeah you hiked five miles and it's like
7:00 in the morning like I gotta go to
work first and this stretcher gotta be
prepared you for any situation
actually we are going to take a lap
we're going to warm up real quick so
domi strips trains themselves they want
to walk through the seam there be an
idea of the context of what's going on
so as we start shooting everything out
everybody has some reference as to where
we are in the piece nothing is worse a
strained groin stretch is good sweetie
sit slow-mo amen
yo what's going on baby hey B wait a
problem with you at home
Oh
I usually jog every morning today I'm
taking a day off to getting the
character beautiful you have any tips
about jogging yeah look to see the guys
in the back are doing it right
longer strides that's what you want to
do it's not about how the pace of your
feet is about the length of your stride
he's showing off he's just showing off
it doesn't need to go that fast I gave
you I pulled the spreadsheet I will
generate a random number and you'll tell
me who the lucky winners 971 nice anyone
all right and what's the first index
what's the first name start at you
all right so somewhere between two and
nine seventy one is a winner of this
month's patreon raffle all right and the
lucky number is
207 here I'll jet away is you get some
sick corridor merch pick a couple cool
things from our stocks sign a couple of
them and send them your way
also let me send you a message on
patreon to your address so please check
your patreon messages Harold thank you
bye
the world series know there are zero out
the guy who's up to bat first will be me
has already gotten two strikes B starts
to be swinging so I whip it you catch it
three strikes you're out good [ __ ] Clint
you're the next one up and you're not
very good at hitting hook you gotta
figure legs on you see knows he can make
the first you can possibly make it home
yeah but a lot of pressures it's the
bottom of the night from home series you
notice he notices something from the
catcher and shakes his head and
something like oh my god they're
communicating and you glance down at the
catcher and you see the catcher is
throwing down a finger signal any like I
could just crash the code I might be
able to in read that moment the ball
flies by so fast owning the chance to
react they had seven errors sacred
goldslick telling me well guess what at
Gibson Phil menu